good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today is scp
2273
object class
euclid
special containment procedures
scp-2273 is to be contained in an
m-shack a medium-standard humanoid
anomaly containment cell with furniture
that can accommodate
scp-2273's weight and size additionally
the containment cell and adjacent
observation or interview room must act
as a faraday cage standard quality of
life considerations apply
scp-2273 requires approximately 8 000
calories per day in order to remain
healthy standard human rations in
quantities large enough to facilitate
this are acceptable the site-17 humanoid
anomaly psychologist is to interview
scp-2273 weekly to ensure continued
mental health of the subject while
obtaining knowledge of scp-2273's
original timeline scp-2273
is a ect
ethics committee type a system of
classification for sapient anomalies
based on threat to foundation personnel
other sapient anomalies and the general
public b sapient anomaly and is granted
limited access to literature and musical
media that may be revoked at any time
description
scp-2273 is a humanoid entity believed
to be of extra universal origin that
consists of two parts
scp-2273-1 is believed to be a
non-anomalous human male that shares a
symbiotic relationship with anomalous
organism
scp-2273-2 this organism completely
covers scp-2273-1
leaving no epidermis exposed notable
physical characteristics of scp-2273-2
are as follows
a kittenous carapace that forms as a
secondary exterior skeleton
compound lensed eyes giving scp-2273-2
approximately a 270 degrees field of
vision and approximately 90 degrees of
binocular vision
earth tone coloration visually similar
to military forest pattern camouflage
advanced musculature that integrates
with
scp-2273-1's musculoskeletal system and
allows
scp-2273 to carry an estimated 1200
kilograms in addition to its own weight
proboscis similar in function to that of
musica domestica common housefly used by
scp-2273-2 to procure nutrients for
itself and its host
colored scar tissue similar in nature to
tattoos corresponding to military
patches and badges these include but are
not limited to
flag insignias rank insignias name
identifiers and unit insignias
and finally a fully functional organic
radio transceiver capable of
transmitting both encrypted
and unencrypted audio messages over a
wide bandwidth as
scp-2273 is incapable of normal speech
am radio receivers must be used in order
to conduct interviews
additionally it is believed that
scp-2273-2 shares its circulatory and
nervous systems with its host
scp-2273 is approximately 2.1 meters in
height and 290 kilograms in weight
scp-2273-2's exterior is heavily scarred
on both forearms and shoulder blades
upon recovery these areas bore open
wounds
scp-2273 claims that weapon nacelles
were previously mounted at these
locations all written tattoo patterns
are in russian and indicate that
scp-2273 was a major in the 22 armored
infantry division no such unit exists or
has ever existed within the soviet union
or russian federation militaries it is
fluent in russian and german
scp-2273 was recovered during an
investigation of a seismic event and
radiation spikes detected outside danner
wisconsin on october 13
1989
scp-2273 was found after tracing radio
transmissions coming from its location
scp-2273 was wounded delirious and
suffering from malnutrition it offered
no resistance to the recovery team it
was moved to 17 shortly after its
recovery
addendum 1
interview logs
scp-2273 initial interview log
interviewed scp-2273
interviewing dr friedrich site 17
humanoid anomaly psychologist
forward
interview was conducted primarily in
german
scp-2273's ability to speak using am
radio
had been ascertained during recovery
the spoken word has been automatically
translated to english for the sake of
clarity for audio listeners
playing log now
hello can you hear me
your accent is atrocious
yes i can hear you
let's speak in a language i know you'll
understand
ah yes all right
i'm told you answer to his name alexei
bellatrov
is this true let's quit with the
pleasantries i am a prisoner of war and
you are my interrogator you killed my
men
tortured me and left me to die in the
wilderness have you not done enough
i
i'm sorry you heard me
don't act like you don't know what was
done to me before i was brought here
my men died because i surrendered
i see now that it was a mistake they
should have died like warriors
fighting for the motherland
i'm not ganded down like animals i
thought i could end the war for them if
the much deserved peace
instead
they are dead
likely not even buried but left to rot
and i am here
being interrogated by some skinny and an
american concentration camp
alexey do you know where you are
no
and it does not matter you will not
break me
filthy dog
end lock
closing statement
scp-2273 remained largely unresponsive
after the final transcribed remarks
dr friedrich opted to discontinue the
interview shortly thereafter
following this interview dr friedrich
put forward a request to provide
scp-2273
a limited amount of low-level
information regarding the foundation in
order to gain scp-227
trust furthering cooperation
a standardized briefing introducing
sapient anomalies to a highly restricted
overview of the foundation and its
mission has since become standard
operating procedure in part due to this
incident and others humanoid containment
specialists and local ethics committee
representatives can be contacted for
further details
scp-2273 interview 2.
interviewed
scp-2273
interviewing dr friedrich
forward
interview was conducted in german
six hours prior to interview
scp-2273 had been issued an outdated
copy of the level one researcher general
debrief in an attempt to make it
understand the nature of its containment
playing log now
alexi are you ready to talk
i understand now
you
you are not dogs
you are crows
i'm sorry
cross it is red army's officer slang for
your people you do not fight in the war
instead you steal weapons from both
sides for
whatever purpose is containment i
suppose
i suppose this means i am
no longer in the place i came from no
yes alexi that's right we need to find
out where you came from so we might be
able to figure out a way how you got
here and possibly come up with a way to
get you back
do not lie to me scary crow you are
going to keep me in this shell forever
you and i both know this
fine
i won't lie to you
yes you will probably spend the rest of
your life in this facility but it
doesn't have to be entirely miserable if
you help us we'll see what we can do to
help you
please
just let me be for a while
all right alexey
take your time
we'll talk whenever you are ready okay
end log
closing statement
scp-2273 began showing signs of severe
stress shortly after reading the issued
document
however most signs and acts of
aggression seem to have ceased
scp-2273 interview 3
interviewed scp-2273
interviewing dr friedrich
forward
interview was conducted in german this
interview took place upon scp 2273's
request
three days after interview two
playing log now
alexi
you said you wanted to see me
yes
i have thought about your offer and i
would like to talk i don't know beyond
all doubt that you're not working for
the americans so
i won't tell you anything that you
wouldn't already know
this is fair huh
yes i suppose
it's a fair offer
okay
you kept talking about a war
what can you tell us about that
it is the second great patriotic war the
war to end the world seven years ago
when i was an only child the americans
launched a nuclear attack against the
motherland and her allies were
retaliated in full force
very few people were left alive and much
of the surface was rendered unusable for
farming or even just living that is why
i am in this armor i couldn't survive
very long in the surface without it
oh
okay
what can you tell me about your armor
it was built for us by the engineers
i don't know how
they do it or how they work but
this armor has saved my life more times
than i can count
and has been worth the pain it has
caused me
can you elaborate on that how has his
armor caused you pain
the armor takes many years to grow i was
only a boy when my parents volunteered
me for the program and getting attached
to the armor was likely the most painful
thing i have ever felt in my life
but it was worth it because i am that
much more of a warrior for my country
everything it feels
i feel
everything it sees i see
everything it smells or tastes or hears
i smell and taste
and hear
everything it thinks i think
i'm i'm sorry
your armor sinks
yes but not how you and i think
it identifies targets weapons ammunition
supplies friends and foes
objectives to be captured
terrain features hazards
it helped me to formulate battle plans
when i am acting in my capacity as an
officer and helps me to fight war when i
am acting in my capacity as a soldier
you already see how it helps me speak to
my men and my superiors from great
distances
it lets me hear the enemy from a great
distance as well
this armor has served me well
okay
i think i understand
can you tell me about how you got the
wounds on your shoulders and arms
when you found me i had just been
captured by the americans they had
forcibly removed my weapons and my
supply pack
creating these wounds
they did this with all my surviving men
then they identified me as the
commanding officer and took me aside
they shot my men shortly afterwards i
thought you were the same americans who
had captured me i still don't trust you
but i don't believe i have a choice
what can you tell me about how you got
here do you know
i don't know how i ended up here all i
remember is a bright flash of light
then all the americans were gone there
were trees that hadn't been there before
but i was very deep in american
territory and i didn't believe they
would dispose of an officer such as
myself so easily
so
i began
sending encrypted distress codes and
wandered the forest until your men found
me
is there anything else you would like to
know
no alexi that's enough for now
thank you
what did you say your name was
you may call me dr friedrich
i appreciate what you have told me so
far alexey
thank you dr friedrich
end log
closing notes
scp-2273
showed significantly reduced signs of
stress following this interview
further interviews are recommended
scp-2273 interview 4
interviewed scp-2273
interviewing dr friedrich
forward
interview was conducted in german this
interview took place the day after
interview 3
playing log
now
hello is there more you would like to
discuss yes actually there is
thank you for asking alexi before we
continue
may i make a request
tell me what you need and i'll see what
i can do for you
you
wouldn't happen to have recordings of
the russian composer peter elijkowski
with you
i'll see what i can find him
thank you
now what is it that you wanted to talk
about
yesterday uh when we were speaking you
mentioned that your suit was built by
engineers what can you tell us about
them
well
they cannot live unprotected on the
surface like you or i
but i don't think they have ever built
armor for themselves
if i would say
do you know
i am not sure
i think it's because only soldiers wear
armor and it is not their war what do
you mean
not zero war is there people too juansei
cru do you not have engineers here in
this world they are very much not like
us
they fear the sun
and have coats like beasts but are
smarter than any man
skinny or armored crow
dog or soviet patriot
any man you may ever meet they are what
has made the modern war possible
for both sides
i see
what else can you tell me about them
they weren't truly known to man until
the years of the great war and the
revolution the french found them in
buried cities where the western allies
were digging their trenches eventually
they were made to build weapons for the
war by both sides this war led to the
revolution and to the end of germany i
can see by the look in your eyes that
you know something or what i'm talking
about this is good
perhaps your world and mine aren't so
different then no
it
would seem not
end log
closing statement
scp-2273's request for musical media has
been submitted
approval is pending
scp-2273
interview 119
interviewed scp-2273
dr friedrich
forward
interview was conducted in german this
interview took place as part of standard
weekly interviews
at this point in time
scp-2273 had been in containment for
approximately two years
playing log now
hello alexi how are you feelings this
afternoon
well enough doctor
the last books you've given me have been
interesting
this traveler through time
from the englishman's novel
he
reminds me of myself
how so
he has seen many things he did not think
he would ever see his travels have taken
him to
dark places he wished he had not been he
saw the world die and he has gone
somewhere he cannot return from
leaving his friends behind
this is true for me also
i see
do you want me to let you keep that on
for your collection then
yes doctor
thank you okay
i'll see what i can do
is anything else you would like to talk
about
yes dr frederick
there is
i've been having trouble sleeping at
night
i know you don't have technicians here
but
i'm afraid my hormone might be
malfunctioning
if you could somehow remedy that it
would be
appreciated malfunctioning
how
well it keeps dragging up old memories
as i'm trying to sleep
that's one of the functions it lets me
remember details i'd otherwise forget in
order to keep me safe while on the front
but now it's showing me scenes from the
war
things i i don't need anymore
actually
forget it doctor this is a problem for
the technician and you don't have any
here i'll learn to cop alexia i don't
think that's
are you sure you don't want to talk
about this how long has this been going
on i said don't worry about it dr
friedrich it will be fine alexia i am
your doctor i am trained to make sure
people in your
predicament stay healthy if something is
bothering you
you need to let me know
now what sort of things are you
remembering before you go to sleep
after approximately 30 seconds of
hesitation
i told you where i was before your men
found me da i
i see my men's faces staring up at me
from the dirt doctor asking me why i
didn't keep them safe
why i was allowed to live
while they had to die
i trained alongside those men for years
before they put us back on the surface
since we were all young children we were
brothers and i gave the order to
surrender
and god
got them killed i should have died with
them i am no better the american dog
should shut them i don't want to feel
this way anymore
please make me stop
at this point
scp-2273 rose from its seat and
approached the interview window as it
did so radio white noise began being
recorded by all radio receiver equipment
within
scp-2273's containment unit and
interview room this static continued for
the remainder of the interview
i was only trying to keep them safe
doctor why couldn't i have died with
them
[Applause]
closing statement
dr friedrich has recommended downgrading
scp-2273 to an ect seized sapient
anomaly granting it limited social
privileges for the sake of relieving
stress
this proposal is currently under review
by representatives on the ethics
committee and site-17 security staff
further statements redacted as per
hippocrates protocol access requires
ethics committee or overseer permission
person of interest file 2273
01
legal name alexi bellatrop
alias is used father anvil
associated groups of interest the
eastern clockwork orthodox church
reason for monitoring person of interest
is a former scp object person of
interest may possess sensitive
information regarding scp foundation
operations and assets
course of action monitor communications
through standard channels detain if
information leak is detected
updated 2063 1101 monitor known and
suspected points of contact carry out
information control measures if
information leak is detected
priority low
status currently believed to be living
in eastern clockworth orthodoxy
monastery in volgograd obliged russia
updated
2063 1101 person of interest is deceased
interred in the graveyard of the
volgograd eastern clockwork orthodoxy
monastery
background information person of
interest was contained as
scp-2273 by foundation from 1989 until
2018. upon hypothetical lifted veil
scenario 2217 having been realized
scp-2273 was released alongside all
other applicable type c sapient
anomalies with provisional person of
interest status person of interest was
given passage to volgograd russian
federation through the mana charitable
foundation's anomaly registration
project person of interest sought
employment with russian federation
government but was denied due to
anomalous status person of interest
participated in televised radio and
online interviews but was unable to find
permanent employment
in april of 2020 person of interest
223701 contacted the mcf's volgograd
office for anomaly registration seeking
discrete relocation mcf internal
documents indicate that several
displaced anomalous entities had been
taken in by various religious entities
including the eastern clockwork orthodox
church three weeks following his
contacting the mcf foundation assets
became unable to track person of
interest
2273.01
in april of 2021 person of interest
227301 contacted scp
formerly dr t friedrich site 17 humanoid
anomaly psychologist through written
correspondence person of interest did
not disclose his location and the listed
address was a known mcf mail handling
center correspondence was hand written
scp reciprocated person of interest
227301's correspondence quickly
resulting in the regular exchange of
correspondence between the two anomalies
following scp
expiration from lymphoma-related
complications on the 13th of january
2034
all undelivered correspondence addressed
to it was returned to senders including
person of interest 227301s
on the 22nd of february 2034
a phone call from the mcf volgograd oar
was received by the site 17 office for
public affairs the caller identified
themselves as a former scp object but
did not disclose further information
instead repeatedly inquiring to the
state of scp
and when informed that scp was deceased
requested contact information for next
of kin as such information is considered
sensitive this request was denied it is
believed at this time that the person
responsible for this interaction was
person of interest 227301
no further information regarding person
of interest 2273.01
or status was obtained until the mcf
office for public affairs released a
public statement declaring that person
of interest
227301 had expired of natural causes one
decade prior this public statement also
published several previously unavailable
documents regarding person of interest
2273
01
several selected transcribed pieces of
correspondence and other related
documents are attached to this document
personality profile of person of
interest 227301
as indicated by these and similar
unattached documents indicate that
person of interest 2273-1 was a minimal
informational security risk to the
foundation
attached documents
selected pieces of correspondence
addressed to scp
correspondence addressed to scp
dated 31st of march 2021
dear doctor
i'm sorry it's taken me so long to
contact you
i've been busy as far as i can tell
you're still facing your own issues i
wish that this wasn't the case if you're
allowed to speak about it i'd like to
know whether your case handlers are any
closer to resolving the issue
if it's sensitive information
i understand
doctor
i never had the opportunity to thank you
for everything you did for me
you didn't take credit for it but i know
you had a hand in my downgrade to type c
status that you are at least partially
responsible for introducing me to
victoria and i can never repay you for
it
the nightmares still haven't stopped but
because of the techniques you taught me
i can handle it
there is no way i can repay you for that
the last three years have
been hard
i'm not cement for this world doctor
this is a world of flashing lights and
happy people and air
and food and capitalism and things i'd
never imagined your world is stranger
than the books and music and films i was
allotted ever allowed me to conceive of
people in russia walking on the surface
making phone calls to friends in the
united states
while military personnel from both
countries cooperate to secure peace in
places like libya and syria
it's beautiful dr
and
it's not meant for me
i think of the people i knew in
containment often is it strange that i
miss being in a cell
i miss penny in this damnable card
tricks
i miss playing table tennis against it
what did security call it the
space crab
it was fun to play against it anyway
and i miss victoria
i never told you this doctor but the
reason i was so quick to be friends with
her is because i wanted to make up for
what i did in the toronto bunkers and
elsewhere
i still feel responsible for what
happened to her she was the only one who
didn't show this cast the first time she
met me and she was my best friend in
this world is it strange that an old
man's best friend was a small
disabled girl
on the outside things are strange i was
able to eke out the living through
public appearances for a while
but one can only do so many interviews
repeating the same information before it
becomes exhausting and before there is a
loss of public interest
people on the street recognize me and
either avoid me like the monster i am
or treat me like
a celebrity or a hero that i am not
it's aggravating to know that eyes are
always watching you the way they are up
here this
may sound cold-hearted but i almost
missed seeing russia as a burned and
radioactive wasteland
i had to escape from the spotlight
and i
i hope you understand that
doctor
i can never give you back
what you gave to me and i hope this
letter finds you in good health and
strong spirits
please if your handlers will allow it
write back to me i want to know how
everyone still at site 17 is doing i
understand if there must be some
omissions but unless i am mistaken
and will allow you to see this letter so
please
get back in touch
i do not want us to be strangers
your patient and your friend
alexi belatrov
notes
letter was translated from german this
was the first piece of correspondence
delivered to scp
sent from person of interest 227301
it is believed that the entities listed
by person of interest 227301
are in order scp-191n
scp-507 and scp-163-ex
at time of reception there was no reason
to believe that person of interest
227301
had any information regarding any of
these anomalies that had not already
been declassified following lifted veil
scenario 2217
low priority monitoring remained in
effect at this time
correspondence addressed to scp
dated 4th of september 2022
[Music]
it's strange
doctor for the first 30 years of life i
was told atheism was absolute truth that
religion is propaganda used by
capitalists and monarchs to keep the
many in chains
in the containment i simply learned to
live day to day hoping that i might be
allowed something to pass the time but
here the people who are helping me
they dedicate themselves to their god
and their lives are without worry or
pain
they treat me as one of their own and
ask nothing of me they are more
understanding of my condition than
anyone employed by your foundation
or anyone who tried to help me on the
outside
these are not people in chains doctor
they may be the only free people i have
ever known
i do not have a television of my own but
on a trip to a village a few kilometers
from a monastery i saw 163 on television
it was being publicly presented during
some sort of conference by an american
scientist i'm glad to see that it's
healthy perhaps more public knowledge of
its existence will lead to some
resolution of its homesickness
i could never tell when it was happy but
i'd like to think
it enjoyed our games
on a similar note i saw that pennies
published an autobiography one of the
clergymen here ordered me a copy
it should be here in a few days
i wonder what he has to say from what
little he was allowed to tell me his
experience with the foundation had been
unique
but i suppose this is true for all of us
who have lived on the inside of
containment cells
maybe there's nothing to be learned
there at all
it feels strange to say this doctor but
for the first time in my life i've
started praying i pray for people i've
never met and for people i've lost i
pray for victoria and penny and
all of you gross
i pray for your health doctor and hope
that someday you'll be able to walk as a
free man
please right back when you can
sincerely alexi
p.s
i finally quit
avoiding the issue and have written a
letter to penny
i'll deliver it when i deliver this
and we'll let you know if he rides back
thank you so much for giving me his
address
notes
letter was translated from german
signature line was written with a
calligraphy pen the first apparent time
such a tool had been used by person of
interest 22730
analysis of ink and paper indicated that
it was not factory produced that the
paper had been milled using a
combination of waste plant fibers and
cotton the ink had been locally
manufactured with charcoal and ethanol
with results chemically similar to india
ink later cross-referencing found that
both recipes were commonly used by
clockworth orthodoxy monasteries and
communes
correspondence addressed to scp dated
30th of april 2027.
dear doctor
i heard about what's happened the people
relocated me
they did not want me to return to site
17.
ever since i've been released people
have assumed that i faced abuse
or even my current condition because of
the foundation
and these mana people are no different
i'll call you when i can if you can give
me a good number to reach you i'm so so
sorry to hear about this
please do what you can to take care of
yourself follow your physician's orders
know that my prayers are with you
pennies as well
does this have anything to do with your
other condition
i know the foundation should cover your
medical costs regardless of whether it
is but perhaps your case handlers could
help alleviate your pain if they could
work harder to eliminate whatever it is
that put you in a cell
i don't know i pray for you every night
i don't have materials to make a card
here and my place here has become more
permanent so i can't simply buy one but
i'll do
whatever i can to help you
please let me know how i can help
remember that god is with you comrade
alexey villadrov
notes
letter was translated from german this
letter was received shortly after scp
was diagnosed with stage 3 lymphoma this
was not considered an information breach
though scp
did express distress that this
information proliferated through social
media and other methods as rapidly as it
had as a result of the content of this
letter it is believed that at some point
following his last letter and before the
signing of this one person of interest
227301 had joined the vulgar grad easton
clockworth orthodox monastery as a
full-time member
correspondents addressed to scp
dated 7th of january 2034.
dear thomas
myself and my brothers and sisters here
all pray for a safe surgery and rapid
recovery please when you are able
contact me it has been a cold winter and
the good news will help to welcome the
coming spring
i've lost too many friends thomas i have
known far too much tragedy in this life
i've seen worlds die
i've seen friends die i've made men i
thought my enemy die
i cannot stand to watch another leave
this world so soon but after hinting
about what happened to penny not after
victoria
god is with you i know you believe this
too
you may be unmarried doctor
but you are not unloved you have to be
strong for me you have to be strong for
yourself if you're ever worried that you
cannot find the strength to continue
think of the garden you'll plant this
spring i'd like to share my gardening
photos with you again not many of my
brothers and sisters here appreciate the
simple beauty of a flower bed all the
effort that goes into growing a patch of
vegetables
it's a beauty i'd like to continue to
share
trust in the power of our lord thomas
and trust in the power of modern
medicine
god is smiling on you
please
be strong
with love and prayers
alexi bellatroth
notes
letter was translated from german on the
signed date scp had entered radiation
therapy to treat its lymphoma which had
entered stage 4 and become metastasized
however several cancerous tissues had
evaded detection and scp condition
deteriorated rapidly resulting in its
expiration on 11th of february 2034.
the letter arrived on the 15th of
february 2034 and following analysis for
informational breaches was returned to
the sender address at the mcf volgograd
office this was the last confirmed
contact by person of interest
227301 with foundation personnel or
tracked anomalies prior to his death
selected excerpts from journals secured
following public announcement of person
of interest
227301's departure
except from a journal entry dated 7th of
january 2035.
i'm only writing this to gather my
thoughts
i don't believe i'll be keeping this
journal regularly
today is the day that our monastery
celebrates the birth of our lord
however i
feel no desire to celebrate
all of my friends in this world are dead
my brothers and sisters are partaking in
some celebration outside my dormitory
all of the required ceremonies are
complete
and neither they or whatever is
happening out there now
will enlighten my mother
father cogwheel and mother
both spoke to me today expressing
concern
this is the first christmas i have ever
spent alone in this world so i do not
expect them to understand
though they are both standardized they
do not know what it's like to sit in a
containment cell or what small comfort
may be gleaned from a piece of familiar
music
they are machines stuck in mechanical
ways they talk of confession and
forgiveness but they do not know what it
is like to confess to war crimes to
murdering innocent children while a man
behind the glass partition nods and
tells you that you can be forgiven they
do not know the joy one might feel when
teaching a small child chase or washing
her eyes light up as you tell her
stories
and they do not know the darkness that
can enter a soul when one sees those
people die
i know there is comfort
in the words of god in the schema and
the words of the holy bible
but discomfort evades me now
i do not know if i will ever find
comfort again
but i have survived greater trauma so
i will try
autov
[Music]
notes
this and all further journal entries
were translated from russian though they
were not released until 10 years
following person of interest
227301's debt they were valuable in
confirming that person of interest
227301 had direct connections to the
eastern clockwork orthodox church
however these journals were written
during a 29-year gap in surveillance of
the subject full information on these
subjects activities during this time
will likely never come to light
excerpt from a journal entry dated 16th
of july 2039
strengths in our mechanized salvations
promise to return
why standardization must be sought after
the beauty of industrialization
our mechanized salvations grand design
simplicity found in nature
self-constructing
systems strength of naturally occurring
systems adaptability of humankind beauty
of human ingenuity
notes
page had been torn from the journal but
later replaced page showed wrinkle marks
adjacent pages contained further notes
on an apparent sermon person of interest
227301 have been assigned to right by
high-ranking individuals within the
monastery this is possibly indicative of
promotion of person of interest 227301
within the monastery's religious
hierarchy no evidence of the actual
content of the sermon or whether it was
ever delivered has been discovered
excerpts from a journal entry dated 21st
of september 2053
i have lived a long life
and it has been a painful life
my hairless
memories of mushroom clouds and
radioactive rain and cold concrete
bankers
i spent one third of my 95 years
fighting a war i should never have
believed in
and another one-third of my life within
a cell
never seeing sunlightened being tossed
children's novels to keep me compliant
it has only been the last third of my
life so far
what i strongly believe to be
the final part of my life that i have
seen our goddess is light and mercy
i know that i am a sinner and that
prayer or a modest life as the one i
have lived will not be enough to earn
our goddesses forgiveness but
this does not concern me i have sinned
and i will pay for my sins in kind she
has cursed me such that i may not be
standardized but she has also blessed me
that i may see the wicked in humanity
and may be equipped to speak out against
it i am not concerned that i will pay
for my sins but rather that i have not
fully fulfilled my purpose in her grand
design
we are each of us
cogs and gears and springs and axels and
all other manner of mechanisms in her
grand mechanism
she has been rebuilt and she has
departed our world with a promise of a
return but she was never truly broken as
we are each of us a part of her and she
a part of us
those who do not follow our faith in the
footsteps of our mechanized salvation
and of our son jesus christ i'm not
doomed to eternity as narcissist for the
flesh because they are heretics but
because they seek to make violence in
the world seek to disassemble the beauty
of her grand design
buddhists muslim hindu christian jew and
all others are equals in the eyes of our
mechanized salvation
and it is not those who do not know the
words
but rather those who would hurt our
children who are frowned upon and all of
humanity are our children
i do not believe that my time in this
world is much longer brothers and
sisters when my time of judgment comes
the lord mourned me i would rather you
remember these words the goddess is most
pleased with those who seek
kind non-violent resolution to her
problems because a machine whose gears
grind against each other is a machine
that cannot work
seek truth
but also compassion
the word tsar only works
seek out truth within them
god bless you all
father anvil
notes
the proceeding is the final known
journal entry authored by person of
interest 227301
it is believed that person of interest
227301 had prepared this statement in
lieu of a last will and testament or in
an addition to one mcf and eastern
clockworth orthodoxy documents indicate
that person of interest
227301 was found deceased from apparent
old age within his dormitory in the
morning of 13th of october 2053. less
than a month following authoring the
excerpt this and other documentation
confirm that person of interest 227301
had achieved some rank within the
monastery's religious hierarchy though a
precise date for the adoption of the
moniker father anvil is unknown
closing remarks
at this time it is believed that person
of interest
227301's remains are interred within the
graveyard at the eastern clockworth
orthodoxy monastery where he spent the
last years of his life there is no
substantial evidence of informational
leaks as a result of person of interest
227301
i am recommending this file for closure
agent lakshmi turnbau foundation records
and informational security
administration
okay on that slightly sad note
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
anvil
aletreon
derivative
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
tailored printers
clad the lad
perpetually confused mate tech pilot
signar
your local foundation agent
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
sayo dio damnares
eric corbige
longinus
the morrigan
karim el ashmuy
james saba
and
nj bojack
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you